Russia is
escalating attacks
with missile strikes hammering
much of that country.
Several regions of the country
have been left without power today.
But Russia's
launch of an over
powering spring
offensive seems to have not materialized,
at least not yet anyway.
Joining us now is retired U.S.
Army Major Mike Lyons.
Major Lyons, thanks for being here.
So it doesn't appear right at this moment
that Russia
has begun this spring offensive
Do you think that it is still coming
I do.
What the Russians are doing right now
is fighting
what's called a covering force battle.
And what they're doing is sending out
small units
well ahead of the main body of forces
they have.
We know there's about 60,000
troops, three divisions
that they have in reserve there in the
in the eastern part of Ukraine.
And they're sending out these small units
to probe
and find weaknesses
in the Ukraine military
and force
the Ukrainian military
to use resources against them.
So I think this is all part
of a grander scheme.
There's no question
Russia has the initiative
right now in that region,
and this is a part of an offense
that's likely started.
But what we're again
covering fierce battles with the military
refers to it
designed to show where the enemy is weak.
And Ukraine's military,
you know in 20, 22
and the last year
seemed to have a lot of momentum.
They were performing,
I think perhaps better
than the Russians expected.
But then six weeks later,
there are new questions
about whether Russia has the momentum.
Now what do you think is playing off
playing out on the ground
I think what's happened
is Russia has started to learn
and that's got to be a sign
of ominous warning for Ukraine.
If if Russia is learning
to do difficult tactical missions
for example,
river crossings we saw six months ago
the Russians had a real problem
crossing rivers
tactically
and survivability of their units
as they were going over.
Now we're seeing them
do it better for Russia
to go on the offensive.
They're going to have to perform
these more difficult tactical missions.
And we're seeing indications
that they're learning from then.
I think, again, that's a real warning
for the Ukrainian military.
If that is the case,
Ukraine will have to do
the same things itself
if it wants to go the offensive
that the Dnipro River
really separates
the two forces right now.
And that's a very difficult
tactical mission.
So on
both sides,
Russia seems to have the advantage
both in the initiative
and then in a learning process.
Tell me a little bit
about the timing here.
How critical is the timing in terms
of how much time Ukraine
has to train up on some of the new,
you know,
supplies that they're getting
from the Europeans?
And do they have
that time, given
that the Russians
seem to be preparing for an offensive
I think it's going to be
a very difficult mission
for them to train up.
Likely they're in simulators right now.
I'm sure training in Germany,
Grafenwöhr and other places.
We brought some back to the United States
for the Patriot missiles.
But until you get on the battlefield
and actually get in the weapons
systems, it's difficult.
The tanks are still not there yet.
We're seeing pictures of them on rail
heads, for example, in Poland.
But time is not on the side of Ukraine
at this point.
And the Russians are going to try
to to keep that initiative,
go on the offensive
and make sure that those tanks
don't get there.
What we haven't seen,
though, is
the Russians try to interdict
some of those supply lines,
go after rail heads,
because that's the only way
they're going to make it
to the battlefield
with any kind of speed and accuracy,
and that is to
get them there on rail heads.
And so
so you haven't seen Russia do that.
They're going to continue
to bomb infrastructure
and go after those high value
targets there.
But but Russia right now
is doing what it does
best, and that is
bring a lot of military power
and capacity, move slowly
and destroy everything in its path.
And we're all. Yeah.
And we're also seeing them
really going
after civilian targets as well,
which has been devastating
for the Ukrainian people.
Retired U.S.
Army Major Mike Lyons, thank you
for all of that.